my name is Jim Hackett and I'm chairman
and chief executive officer of anadarko
petroleum it's a expiration of
production company it's called an
independent exploration production
company unlike a shell or an ExxonMobil
that would have refineries in
petrochemical facilities for making
plastics and carpeting and and you know
shoes for basketball this is purely a
company that goes and tries to find new
resources and develop those resources so
we will will hire people to go drill our
wells will hire people to actually
provide the fluids for that we're
basically more of a field operation for
our production and an office operation
for our different forms of what we call
intellectual capital which would be our
geo scientists or engineers or Treasury
folks are marketing folks in terms of
who we sell to it's it's really a
wholesale commodity and we will sell to
a number of the majors who have refinery
operations because all of our crude oil
has to be if you will transform to a
more useful product like gasoline or jet
fuel and we will sell natural gas to a
utility for example or a major customer
an industrial customer and so we don't
actually use any of the products that we
actually produce except where we use it
for energy consumption on the facilities
in which we produce it from so for
cooking or for again making plastics
will sell natural gas for heat for homes
in the winter
well one is I'm not a good example of
anybody looking out for you but God
because the way I got in the oil and gas
business was actually when I was getting
out of college I had remembered a
conversation I had back in eighth grade
with a girlfriend's father actually in
the Chicago area where we were talking
about what I was going to study in high
school when I was going to study Russian
and he said well if you ever want to use
your Russian come to work at amoco and I
never forgot it and so when I went to
try to get a job after college I went to
interview with amico and through the
interview process I was lucky enough to
secure a job and it then I asked of
course the day after i arrived i asked
well can I go to Russia my first trip
was actually to you egypt i was going on
and audit there and they said we can't
go and i said why natalie so we can't
get we can't get you out and I said
really and I said why and they said well
because we don't have any operations
there and we're in a cold war and I went
oh my god and that's how I got in the
oil and gas business so you do have to
you do have to get lucky occasionally it
turned out I absolutely loved the the
energy field and ultimately knew I had
to go back and get an MBA which I did
and then I went back in engineering but
as you progress through different sets
of your life I think in a career you
oftentimes have a goal for a set period
of time I went to the Air Force Academy
because all i ever want to do is fly my
dad was an Army Air Corps pilot my eyes
went bad in the war ended in Vietnam so
that I had to change what my goals were
then they became to do something with my
Russian turns out the Russian wasn't the
key as it turned out that being in the
oil and gas business and using finance
and engineering skills were the key that
really gave me passion and as you went
along you of course met these wonderful
people who would help you along as long
as I think you're a good person and you
try hard and you you know you actually
care about competence in meritocracy and
so you eventually I think for all of us
if those basic ingredients are there you
tend to be a bit more successful than
you ever dreamed you would be now I
think the definition of success is at
the heart of actually answering that
question about leadership because
there's a great quote that I think
Martin Luther King had about it doesn't
take any kind of pedigree to be a leader
because anybody who serves others can be
in a leadership position you don't have
to have a doctorate you don't have to
medical degree and certainly you don't
have to have a college degree you don't
certainly have to have an MBA but we all
do these sorts of things the thing
you've got to keep in mind is if you
really want to be successful you have to
figure out do you have to do something
bigger than yourself something's not
focused on your own self-interest if you
chase money you'll be miserable you will
have ended up making more than you ever
dreamed of if you do things right but
the key is never to chase that dream
that dream of money and the key is to
chase a dream that is actually about
something other than yourself and I
think you'll end up having a great
experience both in terms of your career
as well as I think you will become a
leader if you adopt that mentality he is
bra system to make sure that you're
always thinking about is the strategy
the right strategy for the enterprise to
adapt to the environment in which you're
in and and when you are responsible for
over 4,500 people's lives that's
something that really really bothers you
it should if you're a good leader I
think and it certainly bothers me as are
we pursuing the right path and is the
management team that that is surrounding
each other in the case of the number of
us who are in the management team is are
we doing the right thing is to challenge
our own thinking and hopefully all of us
are different than each other because if
we're the same we probably don't need
each other and in that process of being
different from each other do we share at
least the same values about how to do
business do you do a right yes you do
and it's about making very hard
decisions about people's lives and about
what the direction of the business ought
to be and so from my standpoint the
first thing is making sure you're
pursuing the right business model that's
the best protection for the people's
livelihoods that you're responsible
directly for that's also the best
protection for your shareholders
investment in you and we have in a
philosophy at our company where our
first objective is to maintain wealth
our second objective is to grow well so
we should never do anything
that puts the business at risk or the
concept of maintaining wealth in order
to grow wealth and while your
shareholders may not be always happy
that you're growing quickly enough at
least you won't you won't stand that
horrible judgment day of actually
destroying wealth someday and so from
our perspective if you have the right
philosophy about doing the right things
the right way you surround yourself with
good people all the things that we read
about in books and you end up struggling
through this very difficult issue of how
do you project the future environment in
a business that is unlike a lot of other
businesses where our investments are 20
to 30 years forward in terms of what we
decide to go and do if you do that right
you'll end up being successful in
retaining the maximum amount of jobs you
can grow in the maximum amount of jobs
that you possibly can as well
you